em
[Música]
primeiro lugar gostaria de dizer que é
um prazer estar aqui com vocês nas
fileiras do Tex uftm e o que vamos falar
hoje é sobre
oportunidades sobre o que elas são do
que elas são feitas e o que fazer para
aproveitá-las e eu pretendo contar isso
para vocês utilizando para isso a minha
história e a minha história como a de
qualquer sonhador é cheia de altos e
baixo e eu comecei muito cedo na vida
tentar ser alguém e eu tentei de
diversas formas e é quando muito criança
ainda com sei lá tipo seis anos de idade
7 anos de idade eu pegava aqueles
pequenos trocados que os pais porventura
dão um troca de alguma tarefa doméstica
e iria e até aqueles atacarejos aquelas
coisas né que naquela época já não eram
tão comuns como como hoje comprava sacos
de bala mas esse sacos de bala não eram
para o meu consumo Na verdade eu
comprava aquelas balas fraciona vá e
vendia durante as aulas na escola
aproveitando a oportunidade de estar ali
E logicamente que tudo que eu fazia né
Eu sempre teve o acompanhamento dos meus
pais irmãos e que nunca me deixaram em
nenhuma situação de vulnerabilidade
social e eu fazer aquilo Porque eu
sentia que eu estava destinado alguma
coisa
é mas se você pensa que essa é uma
história de um jovem empreendedor que
muito cedo ficou milionário e que por
isso vem contar a sua história você está
muito enganado porque na verdade eu
tinha um objetivo e algumas vezes eu até
tinha oportunidade mas porém não sabia
como fazer então quase sempre
o que eu ganhava no saco de bala eu
perdi nas lagartixas de borracha logo em
seguida e isso era um conte no
trabalho e retrabalho que não me levou a
lugar nenhum é mais uma coisa muito
interessante que ainda da época de
criança me sempre esteve comigo foi a
vontade ser o escritor
e eu
falava que gostaria de ser escritores
meus pais achavam que era até por
preguiça eu admirava muito aquele
escritor famoso o Paulo Coelho
eu achava a vida dele fantástica Paulo
Coelho mora na Suíça pasta anos viajando
para conhecer cenário das suas
apresentações
e
eu queria aquilo para mim eu sentia que
eu poderia fazer aquilo mas eu não tinha
conhecimento algum então tive que
esperar algum tempo
mas essa ideia não saia da minha cabeça
e portanto eu comecei a me preparar uma
delas foi entrar no jornal impresso
coisa que eu fiz ainda muito jovem é ir
lá eu me apaixonei de vez foi a
comunicação fiz jornalismo me tornei
publicitário e fundei uma empresa é um
pouco mais de 20 anos empresa é é e hoje
está no mercado mas em todos os momentos
esse sonho de escrever um livro não me
abandonou
O
porém é os acontecimentos da vida me
levavam a deixar esse sonho sempre na
gaveta
os meus desejos sempre eram substituído
por outras coisas que eu julgava mais
importante e assim
procrastinando esse sonho seguiu por
vários anos até que
próximo aos meus 35 anos eu já estava no
auge da minha carreira profissional
naquele momento é como uma vida muito
agitada e eu vou revelar uma coisa agora
que muitos vocês talvez saibam e é me
tornando uma Caroli que eu descobri que
você pode até gostar daquilo que você
faz porém não tem como ser feliz
trabalhando 18 horas por dia todos os
dias
e é neste cenário de total
falta de controle da minha vida eu fiz
diversas coisas tomei remédios fiz
muitas coisas para tentar encontrar o
meu caminho
até que no momento assim de Total
desespero
momento esse em que Eu dividi aí a minha
que eu dividia o meu tempo de almoço que
que era curto é com atividades físicas e
academia ou me peguei até rezando é
porque eu me encontrava sentido para
minha vida Eu sabia que eu me julgava
necessário em tudo que eu fazia
insubstituível e portanto esse dia é
durante uma academia eu disse Deus
espírito-guia ou qualquer outro anjo que
esteja de plantão me deu uma me deu uma
solução me deu uma um caminho eu sou
insubstituível e tudo que faço
tantas pessoas dependem daquilo que eu
do que eu tenho que fazer e do que eu
faço no dia-a-dia mas não é justo eu
constantemente
deixar os meus sonhos na gaveta em
benefício de outros de outros
necessidades
e Eis que para minha surpresa
naquele momento realmente tinha um anjo
me ouvindo e esse anjo me mostrou de
forma muito didática que na verdade eu
estava redondamente enganado
Ah e não só eu como ninguém e é
insubstituível em tudo que faz
bem gente uma coisa interessante é que
cinco dias após Essa oração essa
conversa
é a minha sorte mudou cinco dias depois
eu me encontrava completamente
imóvel numa cama de hospital
cama essa que eu fiquei 36 dias né no
hospital sendo muitos deles na UTI
alguns deles entubado
eu fui na verdade acometido por uma
síndrome rara uma síndrome raríssima Que
chama-se síndrome de Miller Fisher que é
uma variável da guillan-barré
bom então é em virtude dessa síndrome eu
perdi todos os movimentos do meu corpo
perdi a capacidade de respirar a
capacidade é
de enxergar a capacidade de movimentar
enfim eu fiquei completamente
imóvel e
naquela ocasião eu pude perceber uma
coisa muito interessante
logicamente que todas as pessoas ninguém
em sã consciência não é ninguém com a
consciência perfeita agradeceria por uma
doença mas uma coisa muito importante
que é inclusive houve hoje é que algumas
coisas você não pode escolher
Mas você pode escolher como lidar com
elas e isso é que fez a diferença na
verdade naquela a doença me fez ver uma
coisa é
o que antes eu não conseguia né eu pude
ver que a oportunidade sempre esteve
comigo e outra coisa muito importante eu
pude ver é que eu não tinha mais tempo a
perder e que se eu pudesse e que se eu
quisesse de fato eu deveria me organizar
me preparar e tirar os meus sonhos da
gaveta Foi então que eu decidi ainda no
hospital é
redigir um livro que é uma autobiografia
falando um pouco da minha história e do
enfrentamento que eu tive com essa com
essa enfermidade e na verdade esse foi o
primeiro livro sobre esse assunto do
Brasil embora seja um livro muito
humilde ele foi o primeiro livro do
Brasil sobre esse assunto e nele eu
conto um pouco de como enfrentei é tudo
isso né e uma das coisas que que
marcaram nesse período todo e que
realmente aí nós começamos a partir já
vi uma etapa de conclusão é uma das
coisas que muito me marcaram foi que
durante o meu período no hospital além
de ver quantas pessoas com talento e
quantas pessoas que temos uma atividade
muito essencial e que são completamente
frustradas no seu trabalho
eu pude perceber também é
o quanto as coisas pequenas são
importantes de dentro do hospital uma
das coisas que mais me faziam falta
era
ingerir água eu fiquei 33 dias sem poder
sequer molhar a boca e isso me fazia
muito mal eu não entendia eu não sabia o
certo se eu poderia fazer isso de novo
e por consequência eu pude perceber o
que de fato é a oportunidade
então partindo para as respostas que eu
prometi dar no começo dessa dessa
conversa é no meu ponto de vista e
baseado na minha experiência
é a maior oportunidade que qualquer
pessoa pode ter é a vida
e sabes a vida que é um dom e é gratuita
no maioria das vezes as pessoas não
valorizam
e isso
seria a maior oportunidade que se pode
ter
e
agora partindo de agora a segunda o
segundo ponto que eu coloquei no começo
da fala
do que as oportunidades são feitas na
verdade é
baseado em minhas experiências né e de
forma empírica é
no meu ponto de vista
as oportunidades elas são feitas de
conhecimento e se você não tem preparo
se você não tem estrutura para se Quero
Agradecer daquilo que você tem
Ah então provavelmente você não está
preparado para ir além
por exemplo não é raro você ver uma
criança reclamando de ter que andar
alguns quilômetros para ir até a sua
escola ou reclamando por exemplo de não
ter um refrigerante para tomar e ter que
tomar água quando na verdade muitas
pessoas em muitos lugares do mundo
dariam tudo para poder ter acesso a água
e muitos pacientes que ficam anos uma
condição
delimitação
da área de tudo para poder fazer e se o
fizessem seriam muito feliz então é
respondendo essa segunda questão as
oportunidades são feitas de visão o
primeiro. É você ter consciência de tudo
aquilo que você tem e que está acessível
e muitas essas coisas são de graça e né
como por exemplo a capacidade ingerir a
água capacidade e tirar muitas vezes as
coisas são de graça e muito tanto a
maioria das pessoas não as valorizam
Oi e o terceiro. É o que fazer para
aproveitá-las como o meu caso e isso o
que a minha história tem a ver com a
oportunidade é que eu em toda minha vida
né pelo por essa conclusão eu tive todas
as chances para fazer aquilo que eu
queria mas sempre procrastinar vá sempre
colocava outras prioridades deixar os
meus sonhos na gaveta e foi no pior
momento da minha vida que eu enfim
Decidi não adiar mais os meus sonhos
então gente para alcançar as
oportunidades você tem que estar
disposto a pagar o preço você tem que
estar disposto a se preparar você tem
que estar disposto a se organizar E você
tem que estar disposto a fazer acontecer
bom então gente primeiro lugar
e para ter uma vida de oportunidades
reconheça tudo aquilo que você já tem
e coloque as suas metas seus os seus
objetivos de forma Clara
eu reconheço as suas falhas e as corrija
e Trace um plano
Mas acima de tudo isso a maior
oportunidade que qualquer pessoa pode
ter é a vida e isso você já tem e você
tem que ter gratidão por isso obrigado a
[Música]